you
everyone does
.
the
Looks like everyone's here.
porque
We all double check please.
This special session of the Huntsville City Council will be called to order.
The purpose of today's special session is to canvas the returns of the general municipal
election that was held August 25th, 2026.
Let the record show that all members of the council other than Dr. Robinson are present.
Now we have with us City Clerk Shondrika Edwards.
We're going to begin to open the provisional ballots accepted by the Board of Registrars.
All ballots will be counted by the DS 200 electronic voting counting machine.
This is the same machine that's used in all precincts during the general election.
City Clerk Edwards, can you explain to us the process on how we've got to where we are
with the numbers that we have that have been in general viewing and where we go from here
on the provisionals?
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon, council and to all of those joining us today.
If you are unfamiliar with what's taking place, we will be counting the provisional ballots
that required further review by the Board of Registrars.
There were a total of 19 provisional ballots and of those 19, there are 17 accepted by
the Board of Registrars to be included in our official results from the August 25th
municipal election.
And what we will be doing is we'll pass each ballot down.
I will read the district and I will read the candidate selected and we'll start if you
all are ready.
For District 4, Nick Freeval.
District 4, Will Pilot.
Madam Clerk, is it possible to get the District 4 numbers on the screen as opposed to what
we're looking at?
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
District 4, Nick Freeval.
District 2 for City Council, David Little.
For District 2, Board of Education, Holly McCarty.
District 2, City Council, Thomas Casiz.
And Board of Education, District 2, Holly McCarty.
I hate to keep interrupting.
Is it possible for the council to see the ballots before they go into the machine?
It can.
I'm watching her.
But we can certainly let the whole council look at it.
In years past, hasn't the council, well, we didn't have the machine up until the last
one, but the council got to see provisional ballots before.
Didn't we, Bill?
We did, but yeah, this, I'm watching her.
Everything she said is accurate.
We can certainly pass them down to the full council without a problem.
I'd appreciate that.
Okay.
And we, we will have the vote.
District 4, Will Pyle.
District 3, City Council, Liliana Pender.
District 3, Board of Education, Payden Redfern.
And to note, we have one ballot that was split that may not be able to be read in the machine,
but we will be making note of the total.
District 3, City Council, John Stord.
District 3, Board of Education, Payden Redfern.
District 3, City Council, Liliana Pender.
District 4, City Council, Bill Clean.
District 3, City Council, Jenny Robinson.
District 3, Board of Education, Robert Coach P. Person.
City Council, District 3, Liliana Pender, Board of Education, District 3, Payden Redfern.
City Council, District 3, Liliana Pender, Board of Education, District 3, Robert Coach P. Person.
And for the record, this ballot is torn at the corner and may not be able to be read by the machine.
Again, another ballot is torn at the corner when it was open.
Council, this is the last ballot to be read.
City Council, District 2, Thomas Casiz.
District 2, Board of Education, Matt Wolsey.
Okay, now your folks are going to give us an official tally.
And at this time, as they run the final ballot through, we will close the machine to obtain the thumb drive that will give us our official results on our election night reporting system that's before us, along with the official tape.
Can you give us an official count of the provisionals that we just did?
While they do that, Council, let's run through the totals to ensure that we have the same.
For City Council, District 2, Thomas Casiz, final total to City Council, District 2, David Little, 1 City Council, District 3, John Stewart, 1 City Council, District 3, Liliana Pender, 5 City Council, District 3, Jenny Robinson, 1 City
Council, District 4, Bill Kling, 1 City Council, District 4, Nick Preval, 2 City Council, District 4, Will Pilant, 4.
And now for Board of Education, District 2, Matt Wolsey, 1 Board of Education, District 2, Holly McCarty, 2.
Board of Education, District 3, Payton Redfern, 4.
Board of Education, District 3, Robert Coach P. Person, 3.
And for the record, there is no Board of Education, District 4, because Ryan Renaud was declared the winner at the July 9th Council meeting because he was unopposed for the record.
Yeah, we got a total of 27, but you said there were 19 provisionals and only 17 accepted.
If I heard correctly when you started.
Seven. So there are 17 ballots and one may have one race, some have two races. So it depends on the ballot.
Every race didn't have two seats.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
For the benefit of the people that are in the audience and here in the chambers, the tabulation sheets are up on the board on the wall and y'all are certainly welcome to inspect those.
And while they wrap up for us to get our official totals on the election night reporting screen, the city clerk office retain all election results and materials on file for six months, which can be seen at any point.
Six months following a runoff.
And while we wait on the system to update, I do want to thank Madison County staff for being here with us today.
Andrew and Robin are here from the circuit clerk's office assisting us today and we do thank Madison County for the last two months assisting us with our election along with Tom who is on the side.
He is IT. He is the one that was updating the web page at night on election night as we watch those numbers come through.
We are waiting on him to update the web page with our final totals.
Thank you.
It's like a Miss America contest and the winner is.
So we're just waiting on our official results.
According to the data here, we have one hundred and two thousand four hundred eighty nine registered voters in Huntsville.
Only twelve thousand nine hundred eighty nine actually voted twelve point six seven percent.
So we're just waiting on our official results.
Thank you.